Good morning, everyone. I'm Bill Sellers.
Welcome to the session on new advances in bispecific antibody
development. It's my pleasure to chair this session.
Can I get the first slide?
That's the next one.
Okay, so just to start with my disclosures, these are my
disclosures, but one in particular is relevant for today, which is Red Ridge Bio.
It's a company working on biparotopic antibodies, and the topic
I will discuss is highly relevant to that startup company.
So first, for today's session, it's my pleasure to welcome Dr.
Nina Weiser, who's now an executive director of
multispecific antibody therapeutics at Designworks, and Dr.
John Desjarlais, the chief science officer at Zencor.
And I can promise you they will know way more about the way
to engineer antibodies than I will.
So I'll give you the academic view or attempts at
making bispecific or biparotopic antibodies.
So my first experience in this started when I
was at Novartis, and
we were trying to make antibodies against the LRP6
receptor.
And the LRP6 receptor has a series of propeller domains which bind
distinct WNT ligands through different propeller domains.
And what we found is if we made an antibody to the
first propeller, we could block WNT1 binding and WNT1
signaling, but it actually became an agonist in the presence of
WNT3. And if we made a WNT3
blocking antibody, shown here, blocking WNT3-dependent
activation, it became an agonist in the setting of
WNT1.
So
an antibody was assembled, the format of which is shown here, which blocked both
of the propellers, the WNT1 propeller and the WNT3 propeller.
And these otherwise agonistic antibodies became pure
antagonists of either WNT1 or WNT3-dependent
signaling.
So that just says something about the importance of knowing the epitopes and being
able to block multiple epitopes, in this case, to create true
antagonistic antibodies.
So just so we're all on the same page, what is a biparotopic
antibody? It's a subclass of bispecific antibodies,
which instead of recognizing the same antigen,
which is the case for a bivalent monoparotopic antibody,
instead, it recognizes two different antigens on the same
protein. And the way we went about making such biparotopic
antibodies is to take parental monovalent
antibodies and introduce mutations that allow
for the
assembly of paired heavy and light chains,
recognizing the epitopes into a chimeric biparotopic
antibody.
So when I left Novartis and came back to academia, I was very interested in how
extensive biparotopic antibodies could be and how differentiated their
pharmacology might be from standard bivalent antibodies.
And so I thought, what would be a really good test case?
What would be a hard test case, not an easy test case?
And I was drawn to the presence of
FGFR2 fusion proteins in a number of cancers, but in
particular in intrahepatic cholangiocarcinoma, where
the fusions are all on the C-terminus on the intracellular side.
And these fusions, first described by Arul Chinnaiyan, are thought to
activate the receptor by constitutive dimerization.
Yet interestingly, the extracellular domain for all of these is
maintained, shown here. So one question I had was,
well, could we make an antibody that would be potent enough to
degrade or to block the activity of a
receptor in which the dimerization is being induced by an intracellular
fusion event? And I thought if we could do that, that would be really something
special.
So we started by going to the patent literature and pulling six different
FGFR2 antibodies, and by reading the patents, we roughly thought we could
assign different epitope bins to the different binders.
So six different antibodies mapped to the FGFR2 extracellular
domain, as shown here. And then we took those parental antibodies and just
reproduced or tried to reproduce their
blocking ability. So
we created BaF3 cells that are driven by the fusion FGFR2
protein. And you can see when we add
fibroblast growth factor, we can block
FGF-dependent growth with four of these
antibodies shown here, while two antibodies which are not in the ligand binding
domain have no activity. Just for reference,
antibody E is bemratezumab, which is a clinically relevant
FGFR2 antibody. However, if we took those same BaF3 cells, which
are dependent on this fusion protein for growth and don't really need the
ligand to grow, and now we add the antibody,
you can see several of the antibodies become agonists in the absence
of ligand, including antibody A and C, and others just lose
their inhibitory activity in general.
So while they're great at blocking ligand-dependent signaling, they don't do
anything to the tonic signaling except for one antibody,
which in a dose-independent manner, had some ability to
block growth of these FGFR2-driven BaF3 cells in the
absence of ligand. So with these six antibodies, we then used
that duo-body approach I showed you before to make all possible
pairwise combinations, including remaking the parental
antibodies indicated by B. And if you do the math, if you have a six
by six grid, that creates 15 unique biparotopic
antibodies and six reconstituted parental antibodies.
And then we profiled these in a number of assays.
SoFirst, using MSD Set, which is a solution
binding assay,
we measured the affinity of these antibodies.
And you can see, compared to the parental antibodies, almost all the
biparatopics gain significant affinity or
avidity, though in solution, this is really not true
avidity because the two antigens are floating around.
So to try to get an idea of true avidity, we used
acoustic force spectroscopy, where beads coated with
antibodies were displaced by sound from cells bearing
FGFR2 fusion proteins, so we could measure the force required
to displace the antibody-coated bead from an actual
cell surface expressing FGFR2. And you can see two
antibodies, BC and BD, both had the highest
affinity in solution binding and the highest avidity in the
acoustic force spectroscopy, and these were significantly
improved over the parental antibodies.
So these antibodies, along with their parental precursors, B,
D, and C, were then tested for blocking colony
formation or growth
of the FGFR2 fusions. And you can see in colony
formation assays, compared to the parental antibodies, BD and
BC had significant ability to block
colony formation, which is just quantified here on the
right in a dose-dependent fashion.
So working with Nabil Bardeesy's lab, we then took a
patient-derived line that he created.
It's now a stable line from intrahepatic
cholangiocarcinoma patient that is driven by the
FGFR2-OPTN fusion, and we compared the
activity of, in this case, the naked antibodies in blocking
tumor growth shown here. And you can see antibodies BD and
BC had significant inhibition of tumor growth, though
not regression, compared to the parental antibodies.
By comparison, if this model were to be treated with
the relay FGFR2 selective small
molecule inhibitor, we would see minus 20% tumor regression.
So it's not as good as the small molecule, but it's also not so far off.
Interestingly, when we harvested the tumors at the end of the
in vivo experiment, you can see
the striking absence of FGFR2 on the surface.
And we had previously shown that we were unable to disrupt the
dimers, which were our original hypothesis that we would be blocking the
dimers. But now we see instead that we're down-regulating
the receptor. So to further pursue this, we then looked at
internalization using a Fab Fluor
binder that binds to an antibody, and then when internalized into the
lysosome and the pH is acidic, turns red.
And so you can see here that antibodies BD and BC compared to
the parentals BC and D have markedly improved
internalization. And this is lysosome-dependent, as we can block
this downregulation of FGFR2 by treatment with the lysosomal
inhibitor bafilomycin A1.
So that suggested that our activity was
primarily driven by loss of FGFR2 through
internalization and degradation in a lysosomal-dependent manner.
But in the small molecule space, what we know is small molecule
inhibitors, when
patients are treated with small molecules,
end up generating resistance, 60% of which is driven by
kinase domain mutations. And two of those mutations are
really hotspots for creating resistance.
Of course, the antibody shouldn't really care whether there is a resistant mutation
or not.
So we thought that perhaps these antibodies would also work
in inhibitor-resistant settings.
So those two mutations were created in
both BAF3 cells and in the endogenous ICC line.
And you can see from an internalization point of view, BD and BC
still internalized just as well the two
kinase-resistant mutations. And if you look at anti-proliferative activity,
BC and BD have anti-proliferative activity for both of the
intracellular kinase domain mutations.
Again, working with Nabil Bardeesy,
he took that 13-7 model, knocked in a
kinase domain-resistant mutation, so now it's impervious to the effects
of an FGFR2 inhibitor, yet antibody
BC still has activity comparable to what it had in the
original parental 13-7 model. So
as predicted, the internalization is independent of whether you have a kinase
domain mutation. And for me, this raises the interesting possibility that an
antibody plus the small molecule might end up to be a way to
defeat resistance in a combination strategy.
So our model for how this works for FGFR2 is that unlike
bivalent antibodies or improved over bivalent antibodies,
biparotopic antibodies can cluster, drive internalization to the
lysosome, and degrade the receptor, and inhibit tumor growth
in the setting of an FGFR2 fusion.
Okay, but this model also strongly suggests that these antibodies might be really
good as antibody-drug conjugates.
So we then went to take antibody BC
and conjugate it to, let's say, pilot ADCs with
MMAF, a non-cleavable
monoauristatin
payload, MMAE, which is cleavable, and diruxatukimod
using a cleavable linker. And all three of these had
activity in regressing
tumors.Our interest is really in
gastric cancer, where FGFR2 amplification is quite common in the 10% to
20% range. And because deruxtecan-based payloads have
already had significant activity in gastric cancer, we have focused
both on comparing the deruxtecan payload to the MMAE
payload in vivo ADC
models, including breast, colon, and as I said, gastric cancer
models. And in every case, we see significant
regression of the tumors. In short, there are some
differences. For example, this model responds to deruxtecan,
while it does not respond to MMAE. This model has slightly
better inhibitory activity with MMAE compared to
deruxtecan. But in all five models, deruxtecan
conjugated biparotopic antibody B and C have
significant anti-tumor activity.
So it's interesting to try to quantify the so-called bystander
effect for these types of cleavable linkers and try to make
sure it's true antigen-dependent bystander effect.
So as an example, we create
luciferase-containing FGFR2-negative cells,
as well as some of the FGFR2-positive cells that I showed you.
And then we can mix luciferase-positive cells, which have no
FGFR2, with the luciferase-negative cells, which
have FGFR2, in an admixed model.
And I won't show you all of the different controls, but if we now
take either PBS or the biparotopic BC
ADC,
in this case, MMAE, you can see in the presence of the admixed
population, we can kill the
FGFR2-negative cells. So
I don't think this is a big surprise.
You can see bystander effects, but we see robust killing of
FGFR2-negative cells, and in data I'm not showing, with minimal
effects on the FGFR2-negative cells when implanted by themselves.
Okay, so that is our work on FGFR2, both some of which is
published. The ADC
work is not published. But we're interested in the general problem of
how we can generate combinatorial biotherapeutics more
effectively than starting with these 15 biparatopics we had, which is
really sampling a very small diversity of possible
epitope combinations. And one of the papers that really
inspires this thinking, though we're not achieving anything like they did,
is from Chugai, who developed a
marketed antibody called HEMLIBRA, which is a replacement for factor
VIII. And so what HEMLIBRA does is bring factor
X and IX together in a way that replicates what factor
VIII normally does. And I love this quote from their "Nature Medicine" paper,
"To create this type of bispecific antibody, we screened
approximately 40,000 of these antibodies by an
enzymatic assay for FX activation." So
40,000 bispecifics, presumably to find
the one best one that actually could replicate this
factor VIII activity. So this is a gain-of-function
antibody that required really a Herculean effort to find
it. And so we have to ask ourselves, how can we get to that
degree of screening? And I won't pretend to say that we have
some answer to that, especially not in an academic
lab. But
based on work of Aviv Regev and
Nir Hacohen, who developed a ribosome display platform, the Broad has
created an automated ribosome display platform for nanobodies.
And nanobodies, of course, have the advantage of just being a single chain, so now
we don't have to worry about heavy and light chain pairing, meaning the
assembly of different bispecifics or biparatopics could be
conducted much more quickly.
So one of the advantages of this is we can screen multiple libraries and iterative
cycles. We don't have to worry about species
cross-homology, which might block
finding epitopes in an animal immunization
study. So with a new RTK, which we haven't disclosed yet,
we have screened three different libraries.
We are currently screening our fourth.
Each of these libraries is 10 to the 11th in size, but we can
screen these in 96-well format, where each library and each antigen is
in one 96-well. So for this example, from
a new RTK, we retrieved at the end of six cycles of selection,
500,000 unique sequences. By MMseq clustering, they
formed 5,000 clusters. We selected 110 of those
clusters based on things like size and CDRs for further
evaluation. We then took 1,000 of these clusters and performed
AlphaFold co-folding,
and selected 96 that had iPTM scores greater than
0.81. Of the MMseq selected clusters,
44% confirmed. Surprisingly, and somewhat
disappointingly, the AlphaFold predicted binders with
very high iPTM scores were really no better at predicting
than just manually looking at the clusters and picking them ourselves.
Nonetheless, based on these two, we have now something like
90 plus binders. They form four
major bins. They have affinities ranging from two to
138 nanomolar, and the majority of
these
were positive in cellular facts for binding.
So now at a sort of academic scale, we're not doing 40,000, but we're trying
to assembleSlightly larger than our prior
15. And we're very interested in sampling both bins,
within bin and cross-bin pairs, but also low and high
affinity. So we don't really know how affinity might play in terms of
creating the right geometries. And of course, for bispecifics, when target
antigen levels might be different between protein A and protein B,
different affinities might be required.
So here we took, from the four different bins, eight different binders that had
low and high affinity. And to make the cloning way easier,
we just did tetravalent symmetric VHHs,
and now we just have to express one gene, and we form both
A and B, and on the other side of the equation, B and A
combinations. So in this format, we're testing both bivalent and
biparatopic possibilities. So with those 64,
we then did internalization assays.
I'm not showing you all of them, but here are a number of them that are
significantly better than the parental antibodies shown in red
at internalization.
From there, we select the winners from the tetravalent
symmetric format and put them into a knob-and-hold format, in this
case, six candidates now, and test them again in all by all pairs.
And again, we see very robust internalization for the
biparatopics with improvements over the parentals.
And then for this particular RTK, there is also a dependent
cell line that is driven by the oncogenic activity of this
RTK.
And in this case, this is with the tetravalent antibodies.
We have two tetravalent antibodies that significantly impair the viability
of this particular oncogene-driven RTK.
So to summarize, biparatopic antibodies provide differential pharmacology
compared to the standard bivalent monoparatopic antibodies.
The biparatopic FGFR2 antibodies have robust inhibitory activity
in receptor-driven models as naked antibodies and,
well, this should be amplified, and FGFR2 amplified models as ADCs.
I think the ribosome display can be an interesting way to facilitate the rapid
identification of binders with diverse affinities and diverse epitopes.
And this use of single-chain antibodies
facilitates the assembly of larger numbers of combinatorial Fc
nanobodies for further screening.
And of course, we hope to expand beyond what I just showed you in terms of the
64 or eight by eight type combinations.
So I just want to close by thanking the people who have done this work.
In particular, Gal Chatir-Rundabatt has really led both the
FGFR2 project and the second one I showed you.
I'm not sure how she exactly does that, as a mom with three
kids, but she seems to be unbelievably efficient
and bright. So thanks to Gal for all this work.
And of course, our collaborator, Nabil, who we worked with closely on the
intrahepatic cholangiocarcinoma.
Thanks, and I'm happy to take questions.
And you can step up to the microphone if you have a question.
Excellent. You mentioned briefly that on the first
topic that
it works well on the mutant FGFR.
Raul, I can't really hear. There's some other conference in my ear over here.
I can't really hear you.
So you mentioned-- Ah, now it's working.
You mentioned the effect of the biparatopic on FGFR on the mutant
one also, and you said that there could be a rationale to even combine with a small
molecule. It seems that actually as a single agent will work.
Why
you think you will need a small molecule if you can just use the-
Okay. Because I don't think the biparatopic antibody would be
immune to mutational-driven resistance.
So I don't know that for sure, but I'm assuming if we just treated with a
single-agent antibody, somehow the mutations would occur that would disrupt the
binding of the antibody. Those, on the other hand, would be unaffected,
would not affect the small molecule.
So there should be no cross-resistant mutations between these two mechanisms.
Hey, Bill. That's really exciting work. Thank you.
I was wondering in the setting or the context of your
affinities and your architecture, but maybe mostly affinity and avidity,
whether you get different answers to your best candidate, depending on antigen
density, whether you've gotten some insights into how that might drive your
selection.
Yeah. We haven't done that, but there are definitely examples in the literature,
both for HER2 and for bispecifics.
On HER2, there's a paper where someone has tuned the
avidity to lower the propensity
to hit low expressing HER2 cells and only hit the high
expressing HER2 cells. And then for bispecifics, I think for sure, if
you're interested in A plus B, so-called and gated
bispecifics, the difference between the level of expression in A
and B will drive which affinities you want.
Otherwise, you'll just get binding to A by itself or B by itself.
And if you want an avidity effect and gate, I think the affinity tuning
will be critical, and it will depend on receptor density.
Thank you.
Great talk. So,
the last part, you compare the tetravalent format
versus more standard
bispecific-
Yep
... valent, and the result on the cells were not
exactly equivalent.
Can you comment on that?
So, I'm sorry. Again, there's some other thing.
I can't just hear you in the back here.
So you're asking about the tetravalent format?
Right.
And?
Tetravalent versus bivalent in the cells.
Efficacy on cell work sometimes different.
Is it more like a geometry?
Yeah. Okay. So we haven't done every
tetravalent as a bivalent, so we don't have a systematic comparison of
that. So I can't answer that question yet.
Yeah.Thank you.
Very nice work. Did you also consider a degrader
approach, degrading it with one of the
cell surface ubiquitin ligases?
What I thought was kind of interesting is we got pretty good degradation
without having to do any additional manipulation of the antibody.
So we didn't have to target a ubiquitin ligase.
We didn't have to use a LITAC, but we got pretty robust
degradation just by the format of the bi-paratopeic.
So, there's some advantage not to have to, let's say, mess around with the
antibody too much. So I think we were
interested in this idea that degradation didn't need anything specific.
But to answer your question specifically, we've not then tried to combine that with
something else yet.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Okay, well, I'd like to now welcome Nina to the stage to give
her presentation. And the same thing, it'll be 20 minutes and then five minutes for
questions. Thank you.
Well, thanks to Bill and the conference organizers for the invitation to speak to
you today. Can I have my talk pulled up, please?
And so I think my talk is actually perfectly situated between Bill and
John's talk, as I'll be talking about kind of two main themes in my talk
about unlocking novel biologies and an emphasis on antibody
format. And I'm going to do that today speaking on two main topics,
bispecific antibodies, in particular combinatorial bispecifics, and I'll get
into the definition of that in a subsequent slide.
But really addressing the opportunity or potential for novel biology.
So can a bispecific be greater than the sum of its parts?
In particular, can a combinatorial bispecific be greater than the sum of its parts?
And I will present the case study of zenodatumab, which is an anti-HER2
bi-paratopeic antibody. And the emphasis here will be on the comparison to the
antibody combinations. And I'll have a light touch at the end on
antibody format. And then I'll transition into trispecific antibodies and
focusing on the trispecific costimulatory antibodies that are in development in the
field and have a case study of a molecule that's in
development at Zymeworks, ZW209, which is a DL3 CD3
C28 targeting trispecific. And we'll end with the question, which we
don't yet have an answer to, spoiler alert, is whether
the trispecific can be greater than the sum of its
parts.
And setting the stage first here
of approvals of bispecifics in oncology.
And you can see divided by liquid and solid tumors, there's eight
agents approved both in blood
cancer setting as eight agents as well in solid tumors spanning from
2014 to 2025. And what you can see more
clearly here, if you divide the modality type in the setting,
eight of the eight bispecifics that are improved in the liquid
tumor setting are all CD3 engaging T-cell engagers.
Whereas in the solid tumor setting, there's more diverse in the modality class.
Three of eight are again CD3 engaging T-cell engagers.
Three of the eight are dual RTK inhibitors or one
bi-paratopeic, namely zenodatumab,
or two of the eight involve checkpoint inhibitions, either dual checkpoint
inhibition or a checkpoint with VEGF blockade.
And you can further subdefine these modalities into
two different definitions, being obligate
bispecific or combinatorial bispecific.
So an obligate bispecific is a bispecific where the activity is dependent on
the physical linkage between the two specificities, and it cannot be
obtained or achieved with the two separate antibodies with the same
specificity. So you can easily understand how combining a CD3
targeting mAb and a tumor targeting Ab would not result in
redirected
T-cell cytotoxicity. The other modalities fall under the combinatorial
bispecific class, where the activity can also be obtained with a
combination of antibodies with the same specificity.
So this involves the dual RTK, bi-paratopeics, and the dual checkpoint
inhibition. So in the development of this combinatorial class,
these were defined also in a nice review paper from
2019.
One of the questions we ask and was the question we asked in the development of
zenodatumab is, can a combinatorial bispecific show a unique
mechanism of action or have a benefit that is unattainable with
a parental antibody combination?
Again, can the antibody be greater than the sum of its parts?
And I'll introduce here first zenodatumab.
The clinical stage, it is the first and only, so far,
approved bi-paratopeic antibody.
It targets anti-HER2 ECD2 and anti-HER2 ECD4.
It's approved in second-line treatment for advanced HER2-positive IHC-3 plus
biliary tract cancer.
There was a positive Phase III readout that was presented at ASCO
GI in January this year in frontline gastric.
There's several ongoing clinical trials, including Phase III
trials in frontline BTC and in breast cancer post-T-DXd,
as well as Phase II trials in the breast cancer, including neoadjuvant, adjuvant
breast cancer, neoadjuvant locally advanced breast cancer, and other
HER2-positive solid tumors.
So moving on to the mechanism. So it's a bi-paratopeic antibody, and that
was nicely introduced by Bill in his previous talk.
And the one unique aspect of this antibody that we
presented data on is that it binds HER2 in trans, and that's
illustrated here in the graphic. So what does that mean?
It binds to the ECD2 and ECD4 on adjacent HER2
molecules. And this trans bi-paratopeic
binding leads to a cross-linking of neighboring HER2 proteins and
receptor clustering. And the mechanisms of actions that we've demonstrated
is that it adds an enhanced HER2 internalization, reduced downstream signaling,
and it promotes immune-mediated effector functions, including
CDC, ADCP, and ADCC. And so as
ZANI, as I'll refer to it, binds ECD2 and ECD4,
it's essentially like the bispecific version of Traz and Pertuzumab.
So Trastuzumab is a mAb that binds to HER2 ECD4.
Pertuzumab is a monoclonal antibody that binds to ECD2.
So comparing to this as the parental antibody combinations makes
sense, and we did a significant evaluation of that, which I'll
present to you today. And so it wasn't really just an academic exercise for us to
understand is ZANI different than the parental antibody
combination? It was developmentally important for us to do so to understand if
there was clinical opportunity for this molecule.You can see up at the top
the approvals of trastuzumab in combination with
pertuzumab, which started in 2012 in HER2 positive
metastatic breast cancer and all through to 2020.
And so in the zenatuximab discovery started in 2013, so
shortly after and during the first two approvals of trastuzumab in
combination with pertuzumab in breast cancer.
And so this was obviously a very important aspect of our development process to
understand this differentiation.
And on the bottom, you can see I've shown some selected biparotopic
antibodies, or papers, sorry, that have shown
biparotopic antibodies with comparisons to the parental
antibody combination. And here, during this time, also during this
development time, consistent with that 2019 review paper,
these papers show that either a biparotopic antibody is equivalent to the parental
antibody combination or shows enhanced antitumor activity, but
nothing that was distinctly unique.
So no distinct cytotoxic functionality had been shown at
this time for these biparotopic antibodies.
And so I mention again that Zani binds to HER2 in trans,
and one of the first data sets we obtained with Zani was on-cell binding,
and that's shown in the upper here, and this is just binding to
HER2-positive
tumor cells, and Zani is in blue here.
And so one of the things we noticed was that it consistently had this
1.5-fold increased cell surface saturation relative to
Traz or pertuzumab. And so whereas the monoclonal antibody
will bind in a one-to-two fashion, so one antibody to two HER2s,
it led us to question the nature of Zani binding. Is it binding in cis?
So is it just binding one antibody to one HER2?
If that was the case, it should be twofold higher.
Is it binding in trans, or is it a combination of the two?
And so we have a number of data sets that support the trans binding, and I'm
showing just one here. This is an SPR experiment.
Essentially, you mobilize the antibody on the surface of the chip at low
to very high surface densities and measure the binding of HER2.
In a true one-to-one setting and in a setting where cooperativity is not
possible, such as the case as trastuzumab, you would see no
change in off-rate over differing surface densities, which is what you can
see with a linear regression analysis here.
However, when you immobilize Zani or the Zani precursor molecule at very
low densities to very high, at the higher densities, you can see that
cooperativity in the HER2 binding is occurring from adjacent molecules immobilized
on the surface, and hence you can see a reduction in the off-rate, again,
supporting the potential for trans binding.
And so we see this difference in the on-cell binding.
We can see that it binds in trans. But what happens to the HER2 on
the surface of the cell? How does this impact the
localization of HER2 on the surface of the cell?
We think that it's potentially cross-linking HER2.
Can we see it? And the answer is yes.
We did a few microscopy experiments, confocal and dSTORM
super-resolution microscopy, to answer the question, what happens to
HER2 following antibody binding?
And we detected this with a non-competing anti-HER2 antibody.
And you can see in the confocal microscopy with Zani here that
it forms at these early time points of incubation, what we call
the HER2 cap. So this HER2 is all clustering to one side of the cell,
whereas the other, the monoclonal antibodies in the combination formed what we
could see as these microclusters.
And when you look even closer at the surface of the cell at the nanoscale level
using super-resolution microscopy, you can see that these clusters are
quite evident. Number one, that there's a higher proportion of larger
clusters relative to the other comparison antibodies, and that the
overall size of these clusters is larger than that formed within these
microclusters, in particular with the combination.
And so it can form these clusters. So we know HER2 is quite densely localized, and
therefore the FCs are also quite localized on the surface of the cell.
So it led us to think perhaps, maybe this antibody can
facilitate complement-dependent cytotoxicity, which is
not a known mechanism for Traz or pertuzumab at that time.
And so we did
test the ability of zenatuximab to mediate complement-dependent
cytotoxicity in a number of HER2-positive cell lines.
As you can see here in the blue, Zani mediates very
potent CDC, whereas the individual
antibodies and the combination did not.
So these data consistently match that confocal and
super-resolution microscopy data sets.
And consistent with the data above, you can see increase in C1q and
C3 fragment deposition. And another really important thing to note
about this mechanism, it occurs very rapidly.
So this data set here is just zenatuximab incubated with human
complement serum for either five, 15, 30 minutes, up to four
hours. And you can see at 15 minutes here, achieving near
100% cytotoxicity at such a short time period.
And so when you think about the other mechanisms we tend to evaluate preclinically,
ADCC, ADCP, growth inhibition, these
mechanisms to observe a similar kind of potency would
require to be observed over days.
And so when we look at the comparison of zenatuximab to the
combination, parental antibody combination, trastuzumab, pertuzumab in
vivo model, this is data presented by Dr.
Funda Merrick Bernstein's lab, was published last year. Very nice data.
On the left, you can see this is in a HER2-positive biliary tract
PDX model developed in her lab. And you can see that trastuzumab and
pertuzumab mediates, relative to the single agents, tumor
regression. But, in comparison at
closely equivalent or even lesser dosing,
that zenatuximab meets full tumor regression.And
so, and just from a summary of the comparative
mechanism of action and an activity scorecard, again, where emphasis
on the comparison of the combinations, we have really two
situations where Zani is showing something distinct over
the combination. Again, it's the binding and the formation of these large
HER2 clusters which enable a unique cytotoxic function of
complement-dependent cytotoxicity.
However, the other mechanisms did show, in some cases,
equivalent or superior anti-tumor activity or mechanistic
activity in some of the other settings over the combination.
So again, zenotinumab is the first biparotopic antibody to demonstrate
unique cytotoxic functionality versus the combination of parental
antibodies. And so it leads us to ask, well, does it mean anything
clinically? Can we see a difference
in the clinic?
Can we make a comparison? And with all the caveats of
cross-trial clinical comparison, we can observe and compare the
JACOB trial versus the
HORIZON-GEA101 trial, which was presented recently at ASCO
GI. In the JACOB trial, it was pertuzumab plus pertuzumab
in the frontline HER2 positive gastric cancer setting with
chemotherapy. And overall, this trial failed to meet its
primary endpoint of overall survival.
Whereas in the recent Phase 3 trial presented this
year in HORIZON-GEA101,
for the most relevant comparison, which is shown on the overall survival plot at
the bottom here, was zenotinumab plus chemotherapy.
We see significant increase in progression-free survival from 12.4 months to
eight months. And in the interim analysis, again, this is interim analysis,
there's a strong trend towards significance in the overall survival of
24.4 months versus 19.2 months. There's also a
triplet arm where zenotinumab is in combination with tislelizumab and
chemotherapy. And here, both of the primary endpoints read out positively with
progression-free survival increase of 12.4 months over
8.1 and overall survival of 26.4 versus
19.2 months. So this is very promising data.
And one thing in particular to note is that the progression-free survival and
overall survival in the triplet arm were observed independent of PD-L1
status, so that the overall survival and progression-free survival benefit was
observed in PD-L1 negative and PD-L1 positive setting,
which is suggested of some potential for immunological synergy occurring.
And just quickly to touch on some of the formats, we
evaluated again in the development of zenotinumab multiple antibody formats.
And
as
many of the cases published, what's often to see is
that different formats may mediate different
potencies, but not necessarily is the case where you see
particular formats with very undesirable properties.
And I'm just highlighting one example here where we have the hybrid format, which
is actually the zenotinumab format, where you have an scFv and a Fab
comparing to essentially the equivalent, but we call the dual scFv here,
where this kind of Fab has been converted into an scFv.
And so you can see differences in just the overall saturation,
slightly less tumor cell binding over the hybrid, still an increase over
the monospecific here. But one of the key data sets in terms of
this particular dual scFv format, you can see a
loss of growth inhibitory potential and also potential
agonism occurring in this growth
inhibition assay, which we believe was likely due to the spatial distance
between the antigen-binding domains potentially promoting
agonism between the HER2 receptors.
And so now I'll transition into trispecifics.
And before I move into the costimulatory trispecifics,
just to set the stage for the development of tri- and
multispecifics and what's the reason for increasing antibody complexity.
And so for all the tri- or multispecifics in development really are
designed to address some of the challenges we are
observing in monospecific or bispecific antibody therapy.
Some of those are listed here just as an example, antigen escape and tumor
heterogeneity, on-target toxicity, et cetera.
And so the trispecifics and multispecifics in development
are really designed to address one or more of these problems.
As I'll be talking on the costimulation, trispecifics, and
multispecifics, these really are designed to address the challenges
of low T cell function and exhaustion, treatment-related T cell
anergy, and immunosuppressive microenvironments.
And when we look at all the trispecifics and multispecifics that are in
Phase 1 development that have entered, completed, or entering Phase 1
development, the majority of those
fall under the T cell engager modality.
Again, costimulatory trispecifics, there are several in
development, as well as those that have dual antigen targeting in
combination with costimulation.
And so just again, to set the stage of the rationale for
developing, obviously bispecifics are very successful.
We have 11 approved agents in oncology to date.
However, and these are engaging and stimulating the T cell receptor through binding
of CD3 only and engaging the tumor-associated antigen.
However, when you do stimulate T cells through signal 1
only, it can result in a suboptimal T cell function.
It can promote dysfunction, leading to anergy and
ultimately reduced antitumor activity.
So the thinking is, can we mimic the natural T cell APC
interaction with a single antibody?
Can we provide not only signal 1 but signal 2 to really promote and
optimize the T cell proliferation and survival by providing signal 1 and
signal 2 in a single molecule? And so you can see in the table here
some of the molecules that have gone into the clinic or are
currently active in the clinic or will be entering a Phase 1 this
year. These all target either the
costimulatory targets CD28, 4-1BB,
or CD2. The one thing to note is there have been a number of
discontinuations in the field, and for the data that has been published,
I think largely these molecules have been tolerated.
However, there has been quite limited antitumor activity observed
for the molecules for the data that's been published.
And in my opinion, I think this speaks to, with this particular class
of multispecifics, the engineering challenge that does
exist with an engineering a class that, particularly an antibody that
has binding to targets where two targets on a T
cell, because that creates the opportunity where you can have trans
T cell binding. And in that case, you have potential risk for peripheral T cell
activation and also for atricide, or an increase in
activation-induced cell death. And this can essentially narrow both ends of
the therapeutic window.And also kind of consistent questions that we
are faced in this development of this class of multispecifics is: Is there an
optimal tumor target? Is there an optimal co-stimulatory target?
We don't yet have an answer to some of these questions at this time.
And so I'll just walk you through the development of 209 and emphasizing
aspects of the importance of antibody format and also we kind of learn
from some of those molecules that went into the clinic, and we set very specific
design criteria for this molecule,
so that it really had to have obligate Cis T cell binding.
That was the requirement for the development of this program.
And so just highlighting, we screened a number of different antibody formats, and
one thing to point out is in this case and as illustrated in this table, just
looking at say, for example, 10 antibody formats.
When you put the same CD3 and the same 28 paratope in different positions on the
molecule, it has a significant impact on the overall CD3
or 28 binding affinity, just where you place those paratopes in the
molecule. It also has a significant impact on the overall cytotoxicity.
So it significantly impacts the potency of that molecule, where those
paratopes are positioned. It also significantly
impacts the target dependency. This is an also very critical parameter for us in
developing strict target dependency, and we had actually quite large suite of
assays and how we define that. But essentially some of these
molecules fell out for not having strict target dependency.
And so where we landed on with the platform and with our lead molecules,
ZW209, I'll walk you through some of the data.
What we have is conditional CD28 binding, which is another
property that also contributes to that Cis binding that I
described. Here, we've got the trispecific binding to T cells in blue.
When you knock out the 28, you see a reduction, so you can appreciate that avidity
gain with 28 engagement. When you knock out CD3, so only
28 is available to bind, there is no binding of the antibody to the T
cell. So it requires the CD3 to bind for the CD28 to
bind. When we look at T cell bridging in
an assay, we're looking at double positive cells.
We have a CD3 knockout and a CD28 knockout cells.
We have a control. Again, this is format eight, the one over here that failed.
We see no double positive cells with a lead molecule here.
When we put these test articles into just a monoculture of T cells, what
happens to the T cells? Does the test article mediate cell death?
Is it consistent with the kind of bridging we see with the molecule
here? We see that ZW209 mediates no T cell death or
fratricide. When we put this molecule in which we know bridges T cells,
we do observe T cell death. And actually, the first generation molecule,
the trispecific that went into the clinic, we do also observe
some T cell death with this molecule.
Pardon? Oh, I'm close. Okay. I got to speed it up a little.
And so one of the important assays here is this repeat challenge.
Essentially, when you take these trispecifics, and this really speaks to the
potential
of these class of multispecifics, you take them through an assay,
carry the same T cells, and repeatedly challenge them with tumor cells.
Does a trispecific maintain cytotoxicity? Yes, it does.
Whereas you can see that the bispecific here drops out after the second
challenge, as does the clinical benchmark AMG 757 or tartratumab.
And so quickly, as I'm running out of time, these are just highlights of the two
clinical stage molecules. We saw a nice presentation from Evolve Immune yesterday
on their EVOLV-104 molecule. And in this class, they've shown
nice data. They have a CD2 agonist, which is essentially using a CD58
ligand. You see differentiation in their preclinical manuscript, where you see the
trispecifics having greater potency over the bispecific in vitro and in vivo.
And Cytocare also has a trispecific molecule that was presented last year
at ACR, showing preliminary
safety and anti-tumor activity.
And so again, to answer the question, how does a trispecific compare to the
combination of
antibodies? In the case of the co-stimulatory trispecific, this is a very valid
question because there's many combination CD3
antibodies in combination with co-stimulatory bispecific in development.
And here there's two strategies where there's either two different tumor targets
with a bispecific, so a CD3 with one tumor target and a co-stimulatory
targeting with another, or the same target with different epitopes.
And just to highlight really quickly, this is just an overview of
those T cell engagers that involve co-stimulations that are
actively in development in phase one.
For example, CD28 PSMA in combination with CD3
KLK2. The majority of these are targeting
different tumor antigens, whereas there's only two targeting the same tumor
antigens, which does make the comparison of the combination to the
trispecific a little bit difficult, but maybe not completely impossible.
So I'll leave you with the question.
We were able to show in a combinatorial setting that it is
possible for a bispecific to be greater than the sum of its parts.
And hopefully, as the combination data with the cell engagers
evolves as well as the trispecific evolves over the next few years, we'll
get to learn more about how multispecifics compare to
T cell engager combinations. So in summary, zanidatamab is an
approved for the second-line treatment of advanced HER2-positive IHC 3+
biliary tract cancer. It's the first approved biparotopic and the first
instance of a biparotopic to demonstrate unique cytotoxic activity compared to the
combinations. Many multispecifics with
three or more specificities are under development
and use strategies to address current challenges in the field.
And depending on the target biological requirements, some multispecifics
require extensive engineering and format evaluation.
And I thank you all for your time, and I thank the big team who contributed most to
zanidatamab and the trispecific T-cell engagers at Xymaris. Thank you very much.
We have time for a few
questions.Over
here. To your right.
What happened with the follow-up to
Zanudat?
Yes. We had ZW49.
So the question is, what happened to the follow-on Zanudat?
Thank you. Yeah, the question.
The C4 version of Zani.
That's correct.
Zymeworks had an ADC,
drug ZW49, that went into Phase 1 clinical
development, and we,
in the past two years, have discontinued the development of
ADC.
There's a question over there.
Yeah. Thank you. Great talk. Covered a lot of ground.
So you mentioned with Zani, the Fc clustering and how that promotes
CDC.
And there are other Fc receptor-mediated effects that
you see with Zani, perhaps stimulation of innate immunity
or other kinds of immune stimulation that you observe either clinically
or in your preclinical studies
through the Fc clustering?
Yes. We show data in the manuscript.
We look at fairly standard kind of the ADCC and ADCP as well
as the CDC. But in terms of beyond that, we haven't evaluated
that preclinically. But I believe some biomarker assay is ongoing within the
clinical trial.
Thank you.
So I'll ask one question, which is, you spoke about the format and the
importance of that and I guess where the geometries of the binders
are. But I wonder if you could comment on the affinities of the
different binders and how you envision if there's three or four binding
elements actually tuning the affinities of all of those
different elements to the right specificity.
Right.
So if you're thinking about a multi-specific, it really comes down to, I guess, the
mechanism, number one, and the target.
So if you had a situation, you mentioned logic gating as one example.
If you had maybe multiple tumor targets, is one more have
higher normal tissue expression than the other?
Then in that case, maybe you have a weaker affinity to that target over the one
that maybe is cleaner, quote, unquote.
If it's a cell engager,
in the tri-specific where we have a CD3 and CD20 engagement,
maybe having the CD3 having slightly higher affinity than the 28 to
also get that conditional CD28 binding.
So think about it, I suppose, in the nature of the
biology of the drug you're trying to design, but also the target
biologies and the expression levels, I think kind of impact how you go into
the design. And then it's kind of a little bit empirical in terms of how you
screen.
You
would be screening all sorts of different affinities on all of these?
We do. Yeah, we do that. But with some targets, we may know, okay, this one,
we definitely want it to be a lower affinity. Yeah.
Okay, great. Thank you so much.
I'd like to welcome
John to the stage for his presentation.
All right. First of all, thanks everyone for being here, and thanks to
Bill for the invitation to speak today.
How do I move forward, Bill? It's just on this thing?
I believe. No.
Just the right click.
Oh, just the arrows. Oh, great.
Okay. So I was sort of thinking about some of the recent
successes in T cell engagers, particularly for solid tumors.
Collected a bunch of data.
I forget which platform I used to collect all of this, but starting on the bottom
here,
it's been a challenging field.
You can see numerous discontinued CD3
bispecific programs.
Although in fairness, I would say you could probably have generated a slide just
like this for the antibody drug conjugate field about five, 10 years ago.
So,
I think we've learned a lot along the way.
One thing that's particularly notable is you can count them.
There are five discontinued PSMA CD3 bispecific programs.
So,
some of these targets are more recalcitrant than the others, although there's
been some recent movement in that space in terms of mass T cell engagers.
We've got the approved T cell engagers on the top.
So you've got talatinib against TLL3, tibentafusp, which is actually
a TCR hybrid with a CD3 engager that targets
GP100 MHC complexes.
And then you can see here some promising Phase 3 stage programs.
That includes zatarlimab, that's Amgen's steep one by CD3 bispecific
antibody.
On the bottom of that
Phase 3 section, you got
Astellas' ASPO2138, which is a Cloudin-18 2
CD3 bispecific antibody. They've guided that they'll be starting Phase 3 in the
second half of this year. And also pesrotimib,
KLK2 CD3 bispecific prostate cancer, being led by
Janssen.
There is a commonality that leads right into my talk.
So it turns out that the zatarlimab and the
ASPO2138 programs are both using the Zenkor X
cyberpunk 2+1 platform, which I'll tell you more about in a few minutes.
And then just to
tie all these things together, Nina had mentioned this earlier,
I'll also talk about CD28 bispecifics later, and we've got a nice partnership
with Janssen combining with a PSMA CD28 bispecific that we
actually made for them. So,
we could have a whole another symposium focusing just on the bottom, the
discontinued programs and
why and where and how that all didn't work.
But let me tell you a little bit more about the 2+1 platform.
This is a concept that I think is becoming more and more familiar.
I hear this term avidity being used very frequently these
days in a lot of talks about bispecifics.
Our original format was what we call an X cyberpunk 1+1, right?
And emblematic of that is our CD20 CD3 program, which we had begun to
develop in lymphoma, lost the race to a lot of much bigger
players. But we've actually pivoted that, and it's now in Phase 2 for
rheumatoid arthritis.
But as we started thinking about moving to solid tumors, we realized we're
probably going to need more selectivity for tumors versus normal
tissue,
in these T cell engagers. And so you can see we've got a number of programs here
with this particular format.
I'd be happy to discuss why. We'll get to the CD28s
later that we built.
I wanted to ex-explain this general concept of the two
plus one, why it's important, and it's basically avidity-driven
selectivity. And so the way I usually think about this is if you
have a one plus one, that means in order to have
sufficient engagement of your tumor cell and with a
monovalent binder against that tumor-associated antigen, you've got to have a
decently high affinity to engender that engagement of the tumor cell
and killing by the T-cells. That means that you actually don't have a lot of
discrimination between the tumor cells and the normal cells, because you're going
to have a high affinity for both, and it's really not very dependent on antigen
density. And you could see in the cytotoxicity assay down below, you
do get some separation that's really reflective of the
density of those targets on the two different cells, but it's not as wide as you
might want it. In contrast, if you take a bivalent engager against your
tumor-associated antigen, you've got a high density on your tumor
cell. Of course, that's how you're picking your tumor-associated antigens, is
they're overexpressed on tumor cells relative to normal cells.
And what you can actually do is now tune your avidity, right?
So you're actually generally dialing down the monovalent affinity
engagement of both of those arms, such
that you lose activity against the normal cells that have very low
density expression. However, on the tumor cells, because there's so many targets
around, those two
arms can actually keep binding to a neighboring target, and that's called avidity.
It's actually a kinetic phenomenon.
And so if you look at the bottom right-hand cytotoxicity plot,
you can see we can
almost completely separate activity against the low-density target cells in this
assay versus the high-density target cells in the assay.
We've also shown you can do this again and again on multiple
tumor-associated antigens. Now, I would be remiss if I
didn't mention that this is not an idea that came from Zenkor.
Avidity is a very old concept,
but there's a gentleman sitting right over there named Christian Kline, a friend of
mine, that published a beautiful paper, I think in 2014,
making a CEA
CD3 two plus one. And so we built on that concept, and we're
all in on it at this point.
Okay, so as it turns out, Zenkor was not the first
to put a two plus one formatted antibody into the clinic.
We were actually in a partnership with Amgen.
That partnership began when we just had our one plus one format, and
they were heavily invested in this target STeP1 for
prostate cancer. It's a nicely selective target in prostate cancer.
They had been working with the one plus one format and ultimately were kind of
disappointed. In fact, they were ready to pull out of the collaboration.
And Olivier Stolonoovo, who was working with us at the time, got in touch
with us, said, "Yeah, we're not really going to move forward with this." And Greg
Moore, who had just finished validating this two plus one
format, said, "Hey, you should try this."
Fast-forward a couple of months, Olivier came back and said, "Oh my God, we're
blown away. We love what we're seeing." And then fast-forward several
years after that, this is data from the Amgen's ESMO
2024 presentation, and here I'm just showing the PSA
waterfall response plot, where you've got
53% PSA50, 34%
PSA90 at their go-forward dose and a 29%
objective response rate by RECIST.
Okay, so in terms of Zenkor's hands, we had been looking, we
really wanted novel targets, first-in-class targets, because there's a
tremendous amount of competition in this space.
So we'd be done-- Alex Nestal at Zenkor had been doing some
bioinformatic analysis, really pretty simple stuff, looking at
TCGA RNA expression patterns versus GTEx
RNA expression patterns and looking for large separation
between normal cells expressing the target versus tumor
cells. And so you could see here at the far left, the clear
cell renal cell carcinoma really jumps out as being highly overexpressing
of this target. We made our two plus one formatted antibody.
You can see on the lower right-hand side, we get, again,
consistently a higher killing of a high
EMPP3-expressing target cell versus a low EMPP3-expressing target
cell.
Now, I'm happy to present or reiterate some
public data that we showed back in October from early Phase 1 results
from this study. One thing you'll notice, and this is generally in stark
contrast to what an antibody drug conjugate dose escalation schema
looks like, we're up to Cohort 11 as of the time of this
disclosure. There's two reasons for that.
One is because these are agonistic molecules, immune agonists,
we actually have to begin dosing at what's called a Mable dose, basically, where
you might expect a whiff of biological activity in
vivo. That's where you have to start your study.
The other reason that this is not such a horrible thing is that there's
been a lot of learning over time of this concept of what's called priming and
step-up, right? So that you start with a very low dose of your antibody
that basically tickles the T-cells a little bit, gets them conditioned
to the stimulus, and on subsequent stepping up
of doses, you actually get a reduced cytokine release profile.
So you can see in the dosing scheme on the bottom, we start with a priming
dose. We have a step-up on day eight, another step-up on day 15,
and then finally step up to a target dose.
We keep the target dose weekly for cycle one and then start dosing biweekly
for the subsequent cycles.
And just a look at the patient population going into this study.
So these are highly refractory clear cell renal cell carcinoma
patients. There's a lot of enthusiasm for this study amongst the investigator
community, because, for one, this is completely orthogonal
mechanism of action to what these patients have seen
before. So you can see in the prior treatments, which I've highlighted here,
100% of these patients had had checkpoint inhibitors, 100% had
had VEGF-TKIs.61% had two or
more VEGF TKIs, and then now
based on the approval of belzutifan, a HIF-2 alpha inhibitor
in this
data cut, we had 36% of those patients, and that seems to be a growing
percentage. And also just to help you calibrate in terms of the
refractoriness of this patient population,
belzutifan in the Lightspark-005 study, their pivotal phase three,
for approval, they actually had a little lower than a
23% objective response rate. They were approved
basically on a PFS benefit with a hazard ratio of
0.75.
So I'm skipping over a lot of our general presentation on this, going
right to the higher dose cohorts. These are higher doses that we had predicted
based on all of our preclinical modeling to be active doses for this
molecule. And you can see here we've got N of 20
in this data cut. We actually had five
PRs for this. You can see over on the right-hand side, tumor reduction in
over half of the patients.
So very promising at this initial data cut.
And you could see on the bottom the prior treatments that these patients had had.
So again, 100% checkpoint, 100% VEGF TKI,
and a growing number of HIF-2 alpha inhibitors.
Couple of nuance in this data. So those of you paying close
attention probably noted we've got one patient that had a minus
47% reduction in tumor size, yet is labeled as a
partial response. This is something that we actually discussed heavily in
our public disclosure. So we actually had a couple of patients in this
study that were actually misdosed on the priming dose.
That's actually the one dose you really don't want to get
wrong. There was some pharmaceutical
preparation errors. So that patient had actually gotten too high of a
priming dose, probably about fivefold higher than they should have.
That gave them a significant CRS, which meant they had a
delay to achieving the target dose.
But once they actually achieved the target dose on day 50,
then we actually saw the tumor reduction.
So, I'm just the CSO. I would love to call this a
RECIST response, but that's not how the rules work.
But I think it's very promising in terms of the activity of the molecule.
And then the other nuance in this data set is if you look, we weren't
enrolling based on EMPP3 expression because it's generally
about 90% of these patients should have EMPP3, but we wanted
to characterize dependence on that.
And it turns out the two strongest progressors in this study actually had
absolutely no EMPP3 expression.
On the safety side, we actually broke this down into
two different buckets here. So on the left-hand side, this is the tornado
plot for the priming and step-up phases of the study.
That's where all the action is happening in terms of safety.
Not surprisingly, that's where you're seeing around a 70%
CRS rate. The good news is pretty low rate of
grade-3 CRS and no grade-4 CRS.
The other very common AE with these patients is actually a rash.
Also, not super surprising because as it turns out, there
are two normal cell populations that actually express EMPP3,
where it's got a functional role, and those are basophils and mast cells.
And so we believe what's happening in this early cycle of the therapy
is we're actually depleting basophils and mast cells, and they're actually
secreting, releasing histamine and tryptase and so forth, causing the rash.
The rashes tend to be asymptomatic except for the fact that you can see them.
Now, the good news for this program, particularly as we think about continuing to
dose escalate, is once you actually get to target dose, it's actually a very
benign therapy. In fact, I'm hearing from the investigators it's more benign than
the other therapies that they've already relapsed on.
So a very low rate, and these patients are generally feeling
very good when they get up to the target dose levels.
Just one little vignette here in terms of the expression. We did have one patient.
This is one of Monty Paul's patients at City of Hope.
He's been a great collaborator and lead investigator.
You could see on the right-hand side the reduction of that target lesion, about a
63% reduction in size.
Nevertheless, this patient only had about 25% membrane positivity
in their tumors by the immunohistochemistry.
So whether or not this is a bystander effect, who
knows? We like to think that's the case.
More importantly, it bodes well for thinking about expansion of this
molecule into multiple other indications. Right?
So going back to that TCGA RNA plot, you've got the
really high expression of EMPP3 and in clear cell renal cell carcinoma,
you also have a very healthy level of EMPP3 expression in
papillary RCC, which is a very high unmet need and the
investigators are very anxious to get that study moving.
And then you could see if we pre-screen for patients with
EMPP3 expression, we may have
opportunities in colorectal, prostate, and lung
adenocarcinoma as well.
Okay, so I started out the presentation talking about a lot of
discontinued CD3 bispecific programs.
Some of that is for lack of efficacy.
It's often due to
safety signals. And one concept that Anita certainly
has touched on and that we and others
have been promoting is this idea of combining
CD28 bispecifics with CD3 bispecifics.
And this is just the textbook Janeway-like figure that basically the
CD3 gives you the signal one to activate the T cell, and then the
CD28 gives you the signal two that can amplify on top of that
signal one. Importantly,
if you only engage CD28, absolutely nothing happens.
It really needs that signal one to build on, and that's a very important
theme for thinking about how to utilize these
molecules.Now, we had done a lot of work when we
were first building this platform, a lot of in vitro work, a lot of in vitro
validation and so forth. And so I think this is actually data
from our published paper on this B7H3 CD28
bispecific antibody. This is an in vivo study.
This is how everybody does these studies.
These are HuPBMN engrafted NSG mice.
These are established tumors. And you could see if you don't treat
those tumors, you get this very consistent
growing up of the tumors over time.
If you treat with an EpCAM CD3 bispecific by
itself, and we used EpCAM in this case because it's actually a very strong
signal one provider, you get only about 50% tumor growth
inhibition. However, if you co-dose that EpCAM CD3 with our
B7H3 CD28 bispecific antibody, you can
see somewhere around
between
one and two weeks where those tumors would normally continue to keep
growing. You actually see this rapid turnaround of tumor growth and ultimate
eradication of those tumors when you combine the co-stimulatory
bispecific with the signal one bispecific.
And then I wanted to highlight a little bit of data.
You can actually look this up, and Michael had a poster.
Michael Hadvas had a poster yesterday
talking about this data, but it's pretty nifty stuff.
So we've been doing a lot of characterization of the biology, but we wanted to
start thinking about what happens
with pre-stimulated T cells. So on the left-hand side here,
Michael's group basically just pre-stimulated the T cells to the extent
where you can start seeing all the
checkpoint markers coming up in those T cells.
You can see those flows on the bottom of upregulation of PD-1, TIM3,
LAG3, and so forth, both on the CD8s and the
CD4s. With pre-stimulated T cells, when we treat with
a Claudin-6 CD3, that's another phase one program that we've got going on at
Zincor,
you can see about 50% inhibition of growth of those
tumor cells over time. However, if you combine that
with the CD28 bispecific antibody, the B7H3 by CD28,
you actually get, again, complete reversal and ultimate annihilation of
those tumor cells. On the right-hand side is even a cooler experiment.
This is basically a chronic
restimulation assay of the T cells in the presence of tumor cells.
The way this assay works, this is a real-time assay
using the Incucyte system.
As the T cell engager starts to kill the tumor cells, you
actually have to keep resupplying the tumor cells, but you leave the T
cells in the experiment, so they're chronically stimulated.
And so a couple nifty things in this assay.
So obviously the PBS group in green, you see the tumor cells grow crazy
over time.
If we look at the T cell engager only, it works great that
first week of dosing. In fact, for the first dose and
maybe a little bit on the second dose, but sometime around day eight or
nine, it starts to lose its full activity in
terms of controlling these tumors.
If we co-dose with the CD28 bispecific from the start of the study,
that T cell engager can keep doing its thing. It keeps working.
Now, the coolest part of this experiment is Michael wanted to know, okay, well,
what happens if I only add the CD28 later?
And so you see that TCE only, and if we add the CD28
bispecific at that point in the study, then we completely
recover that anti-tumor activity for the T cell engager itself, the
Claudin-6 by CD3.
And this is in fact the way people are thinking about
co-dosing these molecules, is you would actually work through your priming and step
up with your CD3 bispecific antibody, and then once you get
to your target dose, that's when you would start combining with your CD28
bispecific antibody. So important experiment here.
And then I'll just end with Nina talked about the tri-specific approach with
CD28. I would say, and I don't think Nina would disagree, I think for
that approach you'd need a pretty clean target antigen, one that
has very high selectivity between tumors versus normal.
There's the other advantage of the combination approach, and this is sort of that
logic and gated approach, where if you look at the middle here, what
we want is to pick two different tumor-associated antigens that are
both co-expressed on tumor cells,
right? And the idea being that if we have a CD3 bispecific against target
B and a CD28 bispecific against target A, we get that
very strong amplification of those signal one and
signal two against those tumor cells, very strong killing.
On the other hand, if you look at the left-hand side, you've got a CD3
bispecific against a normal cell that hopefully only expresses target
A. You will have a little bit of killing there, probably.
You can't make a completely dead CD3 and hope to resurrect it with a
CD28. So you have to very carefully choose which target
is against the CD3 versus against the CD28.
On the right-hand cartoon, you've got a CD28 bispecific
against a single target B on normal cells.
That's going to do absolutely nothing.
And in fact, we've almost stopped doing monkey
studies with our CD28 bispecifics because every time we do it, we put in
100 mg per kg, and we don't see anything happening.
We just get PK data, which is convenient.
And so I'll just end. Zincor continues to build a pipeline of
T cell engagers. So we've got our EMPP-3 CD3, our
Claudin-6 CD3 also in phase one, also showing early
signs of promising activity. More T cell engagers coming along the way, and
I mentioned earlier our various partnerships with Janssen, Astellas,
and Amgen. And thank you for your attention.
We have time for some questions.
Yeah, great talk. So question for AMG 509.
So based on your talk
Two plus one seems best. They have one plus one.
Why show great efficacy in that data set? Yeah.
I caught the first part of that, but I had trouble-
AMG 509.
Yes.
Yeah. They have one plus one format, but show 53
PSA 50. The data quite good.
But from your talk, two plus one seems best, right?
So why that target SUP EP1?
I'm sorry. The Amgen never had a one plus one against T1.
That's the AMG 509 data.
AMG 509 is a two plus one.
Oh, two plus one. Okay.
Yes.
Thank you very much.
Sure.
In the middle.
Hey, John. Good talk.
What are your thoughts, great intro on the two plus one
strategies and the affinities,
rationales.
Two plus one monoparatopic versus
biparatopic. When do you go one way versus the
other, in your opinion?
Yeah, sure. No, that's a great question.
So,
we have found some good-- So I think it really ultimately comes down to the target
and the epitope.
We have almost always found a situation,
that it's not highly epitope dependent getting that strong
avidity, but it's actually not hard to imagine a case where
based on the just sort of the geometry of the antigen
and
where everything would sit together, that you could actually expand on the avidity,
improve the avidity by having a biparatopic antibody.
That's generally how I think about it.
But all of these things are heavily empirical exercises.
Over here.
Thank you.
I enjoy your talk. Very exciting story about
EMPP3 and the CD3 TCE in-
Can you get closer to the microphone?
Okay.
Now it's better?
A little bit better. You got to get your mouth right into it like this.
Okay.
Yes. Thank you. Very nice talk. I enjoy your talk.
And a very exciting story about EMPP3 and CD3
TCE in RCC. So you talk about to expand to other
indication, because,
for example, CRC also, you have high
expressed EMPP3. I'm just curious,
do you consider like a TME when you
consider to expand to other indication?
For example,
some type of CRC might not have a good
TME,
tumor microenvironment for P cell
engager.
Oh, I see what you're saying. Yeah.
So,
at this point, we really just want to
enroll patients based on the EMPP3 expression, because that's
very clearly an important factor as we go into these other
histologies. I think for the other question in terms
of tumor microenvironment, that's going to be something that
we're going to be looking at as we go through the studies.
And those are not necessarily the easiest things to pre-screen for,
particularly,
there's also a commercial aspect that you don't want to have more than one
companion diagnostic for your therapy.
So,
I think we're just going to have to see
based on the screening on the expression of the target antigen itself, is that
sufficient enough, gives us sufficient activity to keep moving those
programs forward.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay. Here in the middle.
John, great talk as always. So, in your two
plus-
Move. Get in there, Shohei.
Okay.
In your two plus one format, do you
see influence of antigen
engagement on CD3 affinity? In
other words, do you see any allosteric communication
between target binding and CD3?
I see. I would say in general, not
necessarily, right? So we've
got a ladder of CD3 affinities.
We basically call them low, medium, and high.
And
between our programs and our partners, they're
kind of mixed between the high and the medium.
We've yet to find a case where the low, which doesn't sound all that low,
right? It's
double-digit nanomolar. We've yet to find a case
where that actually seems to give us enough oomph in terms of the
activity.
We internally have essentially settled on what we call the
medium affinity.
Thank you.
And, yeah. There is one
important factor,
and it hearkens to the DLL3 example.
So DLL3 is actually a pretty low expression target.
And so in those cases, based on the target density, there's
two things.
Two plus one is not necessarily the greatest idea because you have a
low density and you have a bivalent engager.
You're actually cutting your antibody binding capacity in half.
And not only that, but your ultimate
ability to engage T cells is dependent on that target density.
And so that might be a situation where you want a monovalent engager
and a high affinity CD3 engager.
Before the next question, first we have an online question for Nina, and
I'll say we're sort of in the open session, so if people want to ask questions of
Nino or myself-
That's good, because Christian was probably going to ask me something hard.
So the online question for Nina is, "Since the GEA study did not include the
standard of care arm chemo, traz, and PDL1, what's your interpretation of the
results?"
Can you just read it one more time so I make sure I understand?
Since-
Sorry.
Since the GEA, the gastric study, did not include a
standard of care arm, namely chemo, trastuzumab, and PDL1, I
guess that's the current standard.
What's your interpretation of your current results?
Right. Well, I think, it
does show significant overall-- The triplet arm showed significant
benefit in overall survival and progression-free survival.
So, it is practice-changing, I
think, and dinutuximab definitely has the potential to become the
new HER2 targeted agent in this setting.
So, I think,
yeah, that's mine.
Okay, here in the middle.
Thank you, John, for advertising the two plus ones.
I think where they make sense. And I also agree with your comment on
the CD3 affinity. But I have one question
regarding the CD28, and maybe you both can comment, because there have been
these reports that CD28
is downregulated particularly in elderly patients.
Is that something relevant, you think,
for your biospecimen?
Downregulated in elderly patients?
On the T cells, yeah.
Yeah. I'm
sorry I'm going to give you a glib answer.
I think we're at the stage where we've got multiple phase one
programs in these combinations, and I think that's
a speculative question. I think we're going to have to see how the data plays
out in the phase ones. That's all I got for you, Christian. Sorry.
Yeah. Fully agree. It's a known
data point. Whether it's biologically impactful,
people don't know at this point. It's definitely something that's stated as a
potential advantage for the CD2 or other non-CD28 costims.
So, I think
that's just some others' rationale for maybe not choosing CD28, but
there's no data to suggest to date that it's negatively
impactful or will be.
Thanks.
Hi.
My question is for John. So, really nice presentation, and you
really nicely showed that your two plus one
format compared to the one plus one format, the cell
binding translated to the tumor cell cytotoxicity.
And you showed a nice differential window between the tumor cell killing and the
normal cell killing. I was just curious if you've tested other
formats, a non-CD3-wedged format in your
molecule, and whether you see, and it's more of
a curiosity question, whether you see the binding
translates to robust tumor cell killing.
So, for
non-CD3 formats?
Non-wedged. Your CD3 is placed between the TA arms.
Oh, I see. Oh, yeah.
The C-terminal or other formats, could you comment on that?
And if you-
Yeah. You can move the CD3 around, if that's what you're
asking?
Right.
In terms of the format?
Yes, and have you seen the tight cell binding
always translate to robust tumor cell killing in
those formats? And a comment on that.
Oh, I see. So, there is this very important aspect
of-- And I think it's implied in a lot of the data
that Nina showed in terms of avoiding the fratricide
is, depending on where your target binder versus your
CD3 is, your CD3 engager is,
that spacing can really matter.
And that is also dependent on where your epitope is on your
target. So if you've got a membrane proximal
epitope, it's that synapse distance.
And so, that is a variable that we explore in terms of
tuning these molecules and optimizing those, because it really does matter quite a
bit.
So actually, I have a follow-up to that, which is, in the two independent
antibodies bridging between CD28 and CD3 to two different
antigens, there's neither clustering on the T cell nor clustering on the
antigen side.
And one of the things we saw in CAR Ts is when they made bi-paratopec
BCMA CARs, the activity went way up compared to
mono-paratopec.
Mm-hmm.
I'm wondering what you think about that
independent activity versus something where you would actually try
to drive the A plus B clustering and then drive the
T cell clustering.
Yeah.
It's a great point. I will
say
that when you look at some of the other...
CD28 seems to pretty much work all the time in
combination with two different targets.
Some of the other costims, it's a little bit more of a challenge.
It looks like they work better when you're targeting the
same target antigen. And that gets to your point of the
synapse and the nature of the synapse.
Beyond that,
I would say we like to keep things simple.
We like the idea of a plug and play kind of
situation. So it's not something we've intensely explored in terms
of trying to
further promote. But the bi-paratopics would be
interesting.
Just one last question. In all your newer formats, the two
plus ones, are you designing FC silenced
versions?
Oh, absolutely. Yeah, I would say
just about anyone in the T cell engager field is making silent
FCs, because we don't want to promote any non-selective
T cell activation.
Thanks.
Can you comment on skipping signal two and just
going right to signal three instead?
Using-
I'm sorry, I didn't see.
Can you speak closer to the microphone?
Can you
all of you comment on the advisability of skipping signal two and going right to
signal three with cytokines instead of-
Yeah, sure
... a second?
So, I'll start, if that's okay. So, one thing
that I didn't have it in this presentation, but one thing
that--
So CD28 actually gets you both.Because its
hallmark that we found in all the work we've done is very
strong IL-2 production, and we've seen that in its
impact. If you actually block IL-2, you lose almost all the
benefit of the CD28.
You also get some interferon gamma response.
We actually have had cytokine programs.
So Zencor had an IL-15, a long-acting IL-15,
partnered with Genentech,
did a combination with tezzelizumab, and basically that program is
discontinued.
There's been a lot of discontinued cytokine programs.
I think some of the more promising ones that I think
we're just starting to see inklings of activity are the kind of things
like PD-1 targeted IL-2, PD-1 targeted IL-15, where
you're specifically
force feeding that cytokine to activated T
cells,
and it's a little bit more selective.
I don't know if you want to add anything to that.
I completely agree with everything John says.
I think, again, with the
trispecific or the combination, you get the signal three, so it's there.
And if you were to avoid the signal two, I think,
again, with the complexity and the challenges with the cytokine programs have gone
into the clinic, I think at least, again, going back to the keep it
simple approach, you can have a simpler,
potentially less challenging or toxic molecule and also have the
signal three. And so that's our thinking.
I have a general question. Can you hear me well?
Speak closer to the microphone.
Okay. I have a very general question for the panel.
Why some TCs work, some does
not?
You might just want to ask why do some drugs work and some drugs don't work.
When you think about that-
I know who knows the answer to this. ChatGPT.
Right.
So my first slide with all those discontinued programs, I would say,
and again, this is highly reminiscent of early
days in the antibody drug conjugate space.
Remember, there was a whole class of people got really excited
about this PBD dimer class of payloads because of super high
potency in terms of tumorocidal activity.
As it turns out, that was a bad idea.
And the pendulum has swung all the way in the other direction, where the T-cans are
probably the lowest potency payload, and that affords you
various opportunities in terms of tumor penetration, bystander effect, and then
lower toxicity.
I think if you looked back at my first slide,
a number of those failed programs were monovalent engagers with
very high potency formats. So the BiTE format is
extremely high potency. The DARToMAT, there was a couple failed DARToMAT
programs there, is even higher potency than a BiTE format.
And
I think that just
gives you a very narrow therapeutic window.
So
is there a preferred format for bispecific or for
trispecific?
There's a bunch of different formats.
If you look at the approved
cell engagers in oncology, they all have very similar formats
except for one, which is a two plus one.
So I think
maybe yes and maybe no. I'm not necessarily going to answer the question.
I think definitely with the trispecific, the format, depending on what that
trispecific is, there is definitely
greater potential for a unique format may be needed
for a different solution in a multispecific.
All right. Well, I'd like to thank everybody and especially all the great questions
we had at the end, and Nina and John for their great presentations.
And thanks for attending this session